did the climax of 65 leave your brain
saurus here's a look at all the events
leading up to the nail-biting ending of
65 and how it all came together spoilers
ahead Scott Beck and Brian Woods
co-writers of the first a quiet place
film deliver their third directed
feature together with 65. a Sci-Fi
action thriller that sees the future
collide with the past the film follows
Mills a pilot whose mission to transport
people is upended after asteroids damage
his ship causing him to crash on an
unknown Planet we've crash landed on an
Uncharted Celestial body although Mills
has no idea where he is the film tells
us that he has landed on Earth albeit 65
million years ago when dinosaurs roamed
the land and human civilization was
nowhere in sight with few options Mills
grabs KOA a young girl who's the only
other Survivor and begins traversing
these dangerous lands in the hopes of
reaching the other half of his ship to
possibly Escape while it might seem
strange to see a futuristic Soldier like
Mills stuck in the middle of a
prehistoric world the film does delve
into how he got there Mills is actually
from a distant planet whose people act
and speak like human beings the film
never clarifies what species or race
Mills people exactly are so it's safe to
assume that they must be humans too
mills's people are so Advanced that
they've been able to develop the
sophisticated technology and weapons
that ultimately help him survive even
with those tools though Mills faces
Fierce opposition from both the
environment and creatures he's forced to
fight against leading to him nearly
losing his life on more than one
occasion 65 is truly a future meets past
scenario the Pit's futuristic Tech
against Prehistoric Beasts to see who's
really dominant
throughout the film there is an obscure
red looking entity in the sky that seems
like it's drifting closer to Earth KOA
is the first to see it when she notices
a weird light phenomenon above her
however when Mills sees it sometime
later it looks much more ominous and
massive at first you can't help but hope
that maybe it's just the rescue
transport Mills called for coming down
to Earth but once Mills is able to get
an actual read on what this strange
entity is it's much worse than expected
mills's scanner says that it's actually
a gigantic meteor with the mass to cause
cataclasmic destruction once it impacts
Earth perhaps you are familiar with the
idea that the dinosaurs were killed by a
massive asteroid that caused a mass
extinction event well this is that
meteor and it surprisingly has a
stronger connection to mills's current
situation the asteroid cluster that
Mills encountered earlier which
ultimately caused the ship to crash
actually came from this world ending
meteor and it looks like it's coming to
finish the job
this meteor adds new Stakes to Mills and
koa's escape and plays a big role in
making the finale of 65 super intense
and Visually stunning Mills crashing
into this rough survival situation has a
deeper effect on him than initially
expected and hints at a secret he hides
throughout the film
once he's able to get up after the crash
he sees that nearly all the passengers
are dead and that half of his ship is
missing even worse is that the part of
the ship containing the Escape pod is
nowhere in sight which means that
there's virtually no way off the planet
after his first few steps outside Mills
also sees how dangerous the environment
truly is rather than try to survive he
looks like he's ready to end things
while he attempts to call for help at
first he eventually just tells them that
he isn't worth looking for and prepares
to end his own life right then and there
however he soon finds KOA and she gives
him a reason to keep going given how
harsh this environment is and how
vicious the creatures are it's hard not
to blame Mills for thinking that things
are over
it later becomes clear that Mill's
hopelessness stems from the death of his
daughter Naveen mills's willingness to
accept his fate after the crash is the
first moment that hints at that mills's
relationship with KOA starts on some
rocky ground their inability to
communicate because they don't speak the
same language makes for some frustrating
moments between the two however Mills
eventually warms up to KOA because he
sees her as something more than just a
helpless Survivor he almost begins to
see her as a surrogate daughter while it
at first appears to annoy Mills he
definitely appreciates koa's interest in
learning about his daughter through
video messages they watch a hologram of
her together in the cave and it feels
like a real bonding moment between them
ultimately Mills and KOA have some real
father-daughter energy and some of their
more light-hearted moments together it's
these moments which connect back to
mills's daughter and the way that he
does everything he can to protect her
that make it clear that he sees his
daughter in KOA plus once we learn that
Mills already knows the his daughter is
dead it becomes obvious that he's trying
to make up for what he couldn't do for
Naveen The Vicious dinosaurs in 65 are
certainly enough to make surviving in
this world a daunting task for KOA and
Mills but it's far from the only thing
they have to worry about run while the
big creatures are tough to deal with on
their own
there are also some big nasty bugs that
cause the pair some trouble in their
Journey there's a gut-wrenching moment
when one of the bugs crawls down koa's
throat while she's sleeping that is sure
to leave a massive knot in your stomach
unfortunately the environment is just as
deadly as the creatures they find in it
as Mills learns it's very easy to walk
into deadly tar fields or quicksand
Mills and koa's Cave exploration nearly
proves fatal when a Caven occurs of
course there's also the geyser field
that Mills first comes across after
landing on the planet which spews water
so hot that it could melt skin koa's
main concern throughout the film is
finding her parents Mills initially
tells her that her parents are at the
top of the mountain where the Escape pod
is but he only tells her this to get her
to go on the journey with him in reality
Mills knows that her parents are dead
and only tells her otherwise to keep her
motivated
family there's even a point where Mills
become so frustrated by their situation
and language barrier that he tells her
that he lied unfortunately since KOA
can't understand him she still doesn't
know that her parents are dead until she
finds the destroyed Escape pods this
realization that Mills has lied about
her parents being dead understandably
hurts her and she becomes furious with
him for KOA the journey to the ship
likely feels like it was for nothing now
and part of her would rather just stay
on the planet and die rather than go on
without her parents it's a tough moment
for KOA and it almost seems like she's
not going to go along with Mills to
leave earth when KOA gets angry at Mills
for lying about her parents he decides
it's a good time to tell her about what
really happened to his daughter Naveen
when Mills first left his daughter was
set to go through a procedure that would
cure her of a mysterious illness this
procedure would be paid for by this
transport job Mills was completing when
he crash landed on Earth although he
would be away from his daughter for two
years while completing the trip at least
she would be healthy when he returned
unfortunately Naveen died while he was
out doing this job which means Mills
never got to see her again after he left
the death of mills's daughter is hinted
at throughout the film and there are
some key moments that show mills's
frustration as noted earlier his
willingness to accept his fate at the
start of the film shows the lingering
pain he has from his daughter's death
the video messages from her also start
to take a dour turn that matches the
gut-wrenching feelings of some of the
dreams Mills has about her further the
way Mills views KOA as a daughter and
how he protects her also makes more
sense once it's clear that his daughter
is gone Mills eventually opens up to KOA
about his lingering pain and how he felt
that protecting her was a way for him to
feel like he did something right this
admission helps KOA forgive Mills and
she decides to continue on with him to
try and return to their home
now that KOA and Mills have unpacked
some of their emotional baggage with one
another they have little time to spare
fragments of the meteor are crashing all
over the place and there isn't much time
left until the meteor collides with
Earth they quickly hop into the escape
craft and start the launch sequence
unfortunately the fragments begin to
impact the mountain they're on and cause
the terrain to collapse sending the ship
hurtling toward the ground miraculously
not only are KOA and Mills somehow Not
Dead from that violent crash but the
Escape pod is also still seemingly
operable however it's been flipped
upside down as they scramble to deal
with the inverted spacecraft they soon
realize they have bigger problems on
their hands two giant dinosaurs are
approaching them creating a deadly
predicament although safety seems right
in their grasp this meteor once again
causes Mills and co-op problems that
could put the final Nails in their
coffins Mills and KOA have a lot on
their plate an unflyable ship a giant
meteor racing towards them and two
dinosaurs looking to gobble them up so
Mills Springs into action he's able to
distract the two dinosaurs away from the
ship but his gun is malfunctioning which
leaves him a Sitting Duck everything
seems hopeless again but KOA is able to
show him a hologram of his daughter that
motivates him to kill the two dinosaurs
even better one of the dinosaurs has
actually reoriented the ship by slamming
into it which means it can fly again
however before they can escape the
dinosaur Mills has wounded approaches
them seeking Revenge to protect KOA
Mills sacrifices himself to lead the
dinosaur away from the ship towards the
hot geysers he came across at the start
of the film at first the geysers don't
seem to do much damage to the dinosaur
and mills's wounded leg makes him easy
prey luckily KOA is there to rescue him
by stabbing the dinosaur in the eye with
the makeshift weapon she crafted earlier
this causes the Beast to fall into the
geyser where the intense heat causes its
skin to melt ultimately kills it having
killed the dinosaur Mills and KOA have
one last thing to do escape with the
world ending meteor nearing impact and
Mills severely injured there's no time
to waste KOA helps Mills back to the
Escape ship and Mills launches the ship
they narrowly fly into space just
missing the meteor and make their escape
from this prehistoric hellscape Mills
and KOA even get some satisfaction
knowing that all the dinosaurs that had
been hunting them down have been wiped
out by the meteor and will no longer
roam Earth Mills and koa's Fates are
never truly revealed but they should be
heading to the interception point which
implies that they will be rescued
throughout the end credits the film even
shows what happens at after the meteor
causes the extinction of the dinosaurs
and the evolution that eventually leads
to human civilization although the
climax of 65 kept Mills and KOA on the
run and near death the entire time they
finally have a moment of well-earned
rest
foreign
[Music]